good morning good afternoon good evening
wherever the hell are you in the world
and welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel that's my Spiel for this
Sunday and look who's back oh my God
we're celebrating Harris Harris
is that where my fingers are going
that way
stormy is back with us everybody I am
back
it's really good to be back it was um
fellas it was a long time away
but you are back and you are pumped and
you're gonna be talking about stuff and
things so let's do the title intro thing
and then we'll crack on
[Music]
guys how the hell are we
I'm doing well
I can't believe you're doing pretty well
as well
Matt
yeah I'm good guys my shut up man
hey man look I got a new hot guys I got
a new hat
I like it it's all embroidered on and it
took literally like eight weeks to come
and then the people that make it email
me to say we're taking it off the
channel because of copyright and I'm
like copyright
Martin Matt designed it could it be
copyright that's why I just put it back
off but um I'm just like I think Matt's
[__] dobbed me into the teaspoon yeah
I've claimed copyright on it
yeah but I put it back on again anyway
so yeah oh yeah
right anything that could be copyrighted
potentially oh the giant sleeping
room all this yeah I've copyrighted
black
yes
just hopefully just his belly boy and I
was threatening to show you my bum all
before the live started oh God you're
not going to you don't even want to talk
about yeah that conversation in the
audience does not uh hell I don't even
want to hear it again
I'll I'll deal with my boldness as I see
fit
what solution was not
guys um I was actually with the state we
are it's an open chat we can talk about
whatever the hell we like and I know
we've got one of us that have seen the
new Ant-Man so we'll get Harris to tell
us obviously
um I saw a knock in the cabin door uh
last week which I'd love to I thought
that was a great movie we'll have a chat
about that briefly and I think me and
stormy
for cards have you watched the first
episode sir dude I didn't even know it
was out
I've seen it so I can discuss that and
Matt has just been doing you know stuff
um yeah I've literally just been working
I've watched nothing apart from maybe a
few episodes of Star Trek next
Generation but that's about it
Happy Days
um well like so we'll have that
conversation in a bit so
guys but the point is so anything you
guys want to throw in in the comments at
the side there that you want us to talk
about we can do before we kick over
Harris why don't you tell us a little
bit about Ant-Man because I've been here
news about old quantumania well
let me uh just say this before
y'all goats check it out for yourselves
lower your expectations it is not the
Lord of the Rings Epic Fantasy sci-fi
kind of Star Wars Lord of the Rings
mixture that they kind of advertise it
as because that first trailer you know
with the Goodbye Yellow Brick Road was
just phenomenal but it made it feel like
you were hopping into a Star Wars Lord
of the Rings type of world and the
second you're in the quantum realm you
can tell you're in the volume so just
kind of oh really yeah you can feel that
it's not a big world
when the actors kind of touch an animal
or something you can tell it's not there
that
oh [__] all that being said
manage your expectations a little bit
so it's not that Epic Epic movie that we
expected necessarily but if you go in
thinking this is gonna be a badass super
fun B level sci-fi like fantasy movie
Mostly sci-fi it's great it's great if
it's just like a B level sci-fi movie
it's great like enjoyable time
so Marvel aren't hitting it out the park
again oh no no no no I I've heard a lot
of people say this is their losing the
magic and that's kind of a perfect way
of saying it uh because Marvel movies up
till up till phase four I mean
they hit there are definitely they're
they're misses but up until Avengers
in-game and Spider-Man even after that
no matter what you're gonna have a good
time one way or another
it's Doctor Strange too Darren for me
it's Doctor Strange too and I'm like I'm
not sure then there's them
yeah I didn't enjoy this 10 second
doctor strange as much as I thought I
was going to
I liked it a lot the first time I
watched it and then I watched it again
I watched it and I thought like
it was good to watch like it was it was
like as
no it wasn't I hated it yes Bob is all
over at this point Aunt NATO yes there's
the bad part is that's that's not that
close but it's not that far off either
the thing with Dr Strange for me was the
fact it didn't make any [__] sense
why was Wanda the [__] villain why oh
well that part made sense because it
wasn't a vision no it didn't it didn't
make a sense at all
it just didn't make sense that that was
all directors when she came back
I thought the villain villainization
ever made sense but if you have infinite
worlds just go to a world where she's
dead and take the kids there's so many
options there's so many options thank
you and the whole plot doesn't make
sense because of that I don't
necessarily feel like it's the villain
it's just kind of like you've opened up
this this Pandora's Box and you're
you're not playing around in it at all
the world where rain is tequila I mean
yeah instead of the biggest difference
is
oh green lights means stop red lights
I'm looking at pizza balls going
um
I when you said why was she the villain
just look at your private chats that was
my first thought and I'm not saying it
alive
we have ladies that watch and we'll get
we'll get um in trouble oh God
[Music]
are we working in are we not very
inappropriate I forgot
we can sink I forget sometimes we're not
going to publish having a chat over
beers
but we should be in a pub but it's just
virtual I got Orange Squash doesn't
really count and it's C3PO well I've got
coffee
I got water well yeah you've got your
four liter water jug always yeah of
course
he's so he's so cute and I when you said
lower your expectations
I just thought my expectations for
Marvel movies at the moment is quite low
everybody say hello to Heather
say hello hello
who's Heather
good friend of mine okay Heather can
explain herself to you oh yeah
my birth Mama
finally one of my friends actually
joined the chat hot damn
for the return of the stormy fantastic
Heather it is lovely to meet you hi
Heather and uh hopefully we'll see you
regularly and get into the chat tell us
what you want to talk about my best Mate
watches this sometimes because obviously
I told him that I do this every Sunday
he thinks you look like a teacher I feel
like a [__] teacher sometimes well
we're just a dumbass every time every
time I talk to him and I'll go oh I'm
gonna go live on Star Trek he goes oh
are you going live with the teacher
again
do I teach that's important man because
I could be like the cool sort of like
you know like I don't know I almost said
PE teacher or history teacher actually
all the subjects are crap in that don't
matter
history was the first thing that came to
mind yeah I thought it's true
he's the history teacher saying that the
the pyramids for landing pads for aliens
he's the Daniel Jackson of the teaching
World he's Graham Hancock right here
right here now
what were you saying stormy oh I was
gonna say this is proof that yes I do
have friends
one so so
all that last of us if you guys caught
up on Last of Us what's that I've seen
the first episode
it's it started the first episode is so
good I made the mistake of thinking my
wife would like to watch this and then
I'm still willing to watch it
um so I yeah um at the first episode I
loved the first opening bit from 1968
and he's like talking about
um
yes and everyone sort of goes fungus you
idiot they're mushrooms and then then he
explains it and well by the end of it
I'm like
those answers on about I remember seeing
that in like a documentary like 10 years
ago and it scared the crap at me ever
since the zombie ants I'm like what
and the mushroom spurts out their head
and then to spawn and then like the next
lot of ants go
and yeah
there's a documentary I think it's on
Netflix about
um about fungi and it's just
oh very unsettling to watch I mean it's
just like oh [__] I didn't know all that
other those like Little Things Grow in
the backyard and was spread by spores
insanely hard to kill
they'll go to any insect that's that's
creepy it's creepy creepy
so so you know in in the way I think we
should handle this is we should always
now have mushrooms on Pizza just to
start just to start the war off right so
we should get rid as many as we can so
everybody should have mushrooms on Pizza
should be so so hear me out if we all
just macro those magic mushrooms enough
we should be okay to withstand
the virus or the fungal the fungus
huh
that's my question do we have to just
think small and just micro news
we macro those three times a week we
just oh well good good you're there for
a while yeah I was just starting to
worry it's the new supplements in the
zombie apocalypse
yeah the opinions of uh do not
necessarily reflect the opinions of
sidetrack
if you ever get out here we've we've
definitely got to go a Peyote hunting
yes hunting
yes
coyote hunting well
yes there's a poet I've never heard of a
piano oh my God you guys Jesus [__]
Christ uh
it's a kind of a cactus blue that's
highly hallucinogenic
oh okay
we don't have cactus in the UK so don't
oh look down on us because we don't know
what that is
um we have civilization and stuff like
that we don't have deserts in the UK not
many not yet yeah
um that's pretty much a desert we have
wastelands but not no deserts
Liverpool's pretty much like Detroit
that's um
for Detroit I love this city with the
football team that's that's about it
um
right okay but let's go coyote hunting
instead that sounds much more fun
let's do it yeah yeah but I don't care
how much you said
yeah okay
I've just subscribed to Now TV because
apparently the last of us is on now TV
oh there you go yeah six months for six
pounds how good is that that's not bad
at all that is that's really good so I'm
gonna watch all of it
it's a 10 or a month normally but or
it's it's less than what you blew on
cryptocurrency
I
um as I did in my last video I bought a
load of cryptocurrency and then as uh
being a complete [__]
um I just messed around and I kept
selling it and buying other stuff and
that and I lost a hundred pounds like
immediately
and it was really honestly I mean my
wife doesn't know put it that way
um but now
so I've bought
um three different coins one of them is
called Stargate finance and that's doing
very well hey good I bought it literally
because it's called Stargate no other
reason
um but my ethereum is is on the off and
everything's on the up so I've I've made
my hundred pounds back
so let's see how my area is a good one
to invest in let's see how my Virgin
Galactic Stock's doing let's see here
I had stock in Tesla
um I I got I got a free so I used to
think called free trade and I topped up
like a tenor I think and they gave me
like 20 pounds for free so I had 30 quid
in Tesla and that went up like over the
course of the pandemic and all that all
that stuff so I made a little bit from
that and that was pretty good
40 pounds I did I used to do Bitcoin
trading
um probably like six seven years ago
and I put in I bought two Bitcoins this
was when they were 600 Quid each so I
had two Bitcoins I made 800 pound
overnight
and I thought I was a [__] baller
and then the next day I lost everything
I'm like for [__] sake you know there
were 16 000 now though don't you
the thing is
the thing is the platform I was using to
to do it was called etoro and with
Investments you've got things called
um take profits and stop losses stop
loss essentially if it exceeds what your
stop loss is you cash out and that's it
yeah
um it now they have a thing on crypto
where if it goes that there's no stop
loss you can literally make it go down
to like bang zero
and it will still have the investment
then you still actually have the coins
but back then because it went down so
quickly
everything went
if I'd if I did if it did if that didn't
happen and I'd have waited two months it
went up to like
um 30 grand
since I'm crazy like that I'd have had
30 no it would have been 15 grand each
but 30 Grand in in the series of this
whole thing with the um crypto coins to
me I'm trying to now I've sort of done
the introduction I've said what I've
done and I've sort of given an update
but I'm going to be talking about what
cryptocurrency really is and how people
seem to think that they're all just
connected to nothing and it's just like
magic money and it's it's not some of
the crypto coins if you actually do the
research are connected to things like
the US dollar some are connected to gold
standards somewhere actually but also I
can remember the money in your pocket
here it's only really worth anything
because we all agree it is
so I mean it's not it's not like it's
it's but it is where rich people hide
their money because it's unregulated
yeah so that's fine yeah there's a coin
called usdt which is tether yeah tether
and that's that's the one that follows
essentially the US dollar but there's a
there's a British one I think there's
loads of them there's like um
every like fiat currency has a tethered
version of it and if
um the value of the say it's the British
one say the value of the pound goes up
your coins go up as well yeah so so I'm
gonna so obviously I've come into this
knowing nothing about it so I'm going to
learn a bit about it but I would say
it's so volatile
don't put your don't put any more money
in there than you are happy to lose and
don't watch it every day because it it's
like oh I've lost 50 Quid I've gained 60
quid I've lost 50 Quid here because it
goes it's like that so would you agree
that this none of this should be taken
as Financial advice
um I was just about to say none of this
is
the disclaimer is say that more in the
videos actually I have I thought I'd
said it but I've had a few people go you
really need to say you know this is a
financial advice and I'm like yeah okay
um so I've put it in the description I'm
an idiot do not take Financial advice
from me I am doing this as an experiment
a better investment is to hit the join
button down below you'll get way more
way more like
this is the best investment
um in 20 years these will be worth one
million pounds
yeah it'll be worth one million pounds
but one million pounds would be worth
like 50p of today's money because of
inflation
so how many of you guys are into the uh
John Wick Saga yes this one was yes
never [__] with a man's dog that's
what I said never no no no
did his wife yeah yeah
I asked if they murdered his wife but no
the first one was um it was like a
proper 1980s early 90s action movie no
CGI no none of that nonsense it was it
was like a classic proper I think the
only other time was in a film like that
in the last 20 years so is like the
first taken the first taken was
fantastic again brilliantly acted
brilliant honest brilliant the other two
uh I think they spent too much money on
him
I've not seen the third one yet there's
a fourth one they're making and it's
coming out soon isn't it yeah yeah
sometime soon March isn't it March yeah
yeah it's nearly three hours long
is it really yeah
the new John wicker the new taken no the
new John Wick I don't think
I don't yeah I don't know if there's
anything I mean there's I mean I I I'd
like it to be three hours because I I I
love
um the John Wick films I just want more
and more and more oh yeah I'm with you
after watching the first one I wanted
more so I watched the second one
straight away I watched both films in
the space of
or half a day essentially yeah I never
watched the third one it's still sitting
on my computer I still haven't watched
it
but if there's a three hour film
watch it and then restart it
so it's been the three hour film is
everybody got in their Avatar
with water uh on yet has anyone seen
that yet have you seen anything I've
seen in every single type video format I
didn't like the first one
no
God you're [__] I'm I'm just gonna
take you out of the chat name because
people are going to really start yelling
at you love [__] was there waiting yeah
they had all this hype about it being
one of the greatest movies like of the
generation blah blah whatever I just
thought it was boring it was incredibly
boring it looked nice yeah it looked
really nice but it was boring
it's not the sort of film you would
watch over and over again like predator
or something it just isn't no
umatic mushrooms and we're gonna sit you
down and let you watch out your
mushrooms again
the opinions of Harris
this is not Financial advice
you're gonna get fruits until you like
avatars you got a macro
I'll make a little
not Financial advice or don't actually
do this kind of thing ignore everything
he said in the following hour
yeah the two British guys are talking
since the Americans not so much
I mean who knew that that would be the
case
Sarah Euler agrees with me that Avatar
was meh
I like you Sarah okay do y'all not like
Fern Gully or Dances with Wolves or
Pocahontas
nobody likes films
unless we already micro dosing because I
have no idea how Pocahontas
gets into this
they're all a very similar story the
stories yeah
and why Dances with Wolves just because
it's long no it's just a very similar
plot By plot kind of story same thing
like if you compare Dance With Wolves to
Fern Gully or Pocahontas it's similar
stories in in very many ways and Avatar
just kind of continues the the pattern
forever no okay now I can see that
um but I say yeah I love the way your
mind works it's beautiful
um Dances With Wolves
is I mean that that's a film you need to
start with snacks
and then
and I mean if you're gonna do that in
one sit and you need snacks in a bottle
or something if you're a boy
girl
um but yeah that's a long [__]
um I I love I love the way of water I
thought it's great
um I
was a little disappointed just in that
um I just thought I'd you know I said I
was worried that it was going to be
Avatar just wetter
it was really I mean the the storyline
was very similar and the thing that
irritated me is they went from
things
and get this unobtaining because that
pays for everything and then in the new
film it was we've got to get this wiggle
and we've got to get this brain juice
because that pays for everything and I'm
like no no no no you said full of Rocket
paid for everything what now it's now
it's brain juice make your minds up you
don't have my voice you can irritates me
it's just it was the menu Bob has an
opinion here Bob definitely isn't it
Total Recall is more rewatchable the
first not the second one though Colin
Farrell or Schwarzenegger
not the Colin far along even though they
did have that Jessica Biel lady and it
was very pretty
um no
do you know in those films occasionally
you turn it off and you go I don't know
what the hell just happened that was the
Colin Farrell Total Recall yeah yeah
yeah yeah I win I don't know
high hopes for that one but no
no it was a terrible movie terrible
terrible movie
um yeah Arnold Arnold yeah the Total
Recall though is is a great movie I look
when his eyes pop out when he's got no
air
and then his eyes go back in and he's
fine I'm like I'm pretty sure that would
cause damage
yeah I think that would sting I think
you'd be like oh my eyes elongation of
the optic nerve at least he came out
with two black eyes I mean come on
really something yeah I do love that
thing up the nose maybe some retina you
know let me just just say him but it's a
great movie that's a brilliant sci-fi
movie as well yeah it's just it's just
hey
um so what okay so I've been out so I've
been working my ass off for the last oh
we clicked at the same time
messing around with the [__] things
all right I'm in charge here stop it
yes sir teach yourself
so I went out of things for like last
two three months because
of work what should what have I missed
and what should I catch back up on yeah
oh you bastard you know what animals
gone then so what have you what so what
have you been trying to catch up on then
I've just not being out of it for so
long what have uh what should I start
catching back up on
um
oh God there's no there's not a lot of
good Sci-Fi on at the moment
Picard series one series three episode
one though
is genuinely
hand on heart
the best Star Trek we've seen in
probably two decades really it's it's
coming from you that's saying something
man that's brilliant really
if they tease us with a good I mean the
first episode of series two was good was
was great to be honest
um but this was and it teases so many
things we're going to see more of the
Borg they talk there's things about wolf
359 seems to be mentioned a lot
um it's been teased a lot so I mean oh
man it's it's honestly
so there's so many good bits to it it's
just brilliant so I should watch it with
my pants off is that what you're saying
100 okay we'll do British plants are
American pants
yeah British pants are American oh
American pants or trousers you're still
going to have your pants on okay that's
good okay
um but
taking both off
I got both whatever
starting on the stream next
none of us are wearing pants American
pants are pretty pants
okay so what's the difference between
American pants and British pants
I don't know no one like to say when the
English people went over to America and
they all just went you know all these
pants that we're wearing I'm gonna
really confuse people about 300 years
I'm just gonna swap up
but actually in fact we used to call
Posh trousers pants
but then for some reason we're just
calling all over underwear just got cold
pants I don't know it depends where you
are in the UK as well because when I
live when I lived in Liverpool trousers
were pants
you know sometimes here I'm from I'm
from Essex so it was always underwear
trials or like pants underwear and then
trousers where you're like
what stormy would call pants now
but then what then I was in Liverpool
and then my jeans were pants I'm like
that's mental so they were some sort of
transitionary wall or something between
Liverpool and the rest of the UK is that
what you're saying because it went yeah
I think like as soon as you get probably
like you leave Birmingham and you go a
little bit further north it's probably
around there somewhere are you sure you
guys don't have peyote where you're from
they have Amsterdam kind of closed or is
it just all shrooms for you guys oh we
love a shrimp but they grow in the woods
so here we got we got them everywhere
and the thing is between the North and
the South there is a few of the drugs
one of the examples I had a guy told me
he was like right
when you're having a Sunday dinner do
you have mashed potato
roast potatoes or both
both right potatoes rice potatoes no no
no no no no just roast potatoes no
matter because you must not belong on a
roast potato right does not belong on a
roast dinner
off I live in the Midlands I live in the
Midlands you're from Essex yes I am but
everyone around here as well also from
the Midlands we have both
the north mashed potatoes no roast South
roast potatoes no Mash in the middle
they definitely have roast potatoes up
in livable
they might have but that's generally the
rule is mashed potatoes
[__] snake man you're just ruining my
point
yes
bread roll has different different words
no matter where you go
is this
the site the north side there is a north
side divide definitely because the South
has all the money in the north has no
money and then you hit Scotland and all
of a sudden everything has to be deep
fried and that's the way so Scotland is
not North
no but then that's that's very North
that's like saying that the stars are
from the North and then like the white
walkers are from the
oh okay so
is
the the scotch or the wildlings yeah
they are the wildlings yeah and they're
all Ginger and mad hair Braveheart
wildlings yeah and like I say and we
built a wall there's no there's no
subtlety in the
in the in the metaphor there
um well and just to speak in the wall
that wall didn't work and neither is
ours now
people are people I love some of the
Scottish words that they have up there
but it's normal words but they'll have a
little Scottish twang to it so police is
police
like it's not just an accent thing it's
the actual word is polis p-o-l-i-s
that's what they have more
in this in there they want to be
European more than we do we don't really
want to be European in England
we want to be English and the Scottish
kind of one of the European and we're
like
now they want to be American
huh yeah and you're pissed off that we
are that's it that's I mean I am jealous
of the goodness I will admit goodons are
cool I don't actually want one in the
house so I've got kids but guns are
so um you know I miss I'm I'm yeah I
miss a good gun but come down
I was talking about this we watched Sean
of the Dead yesterday or my kids and
they were like what are we gonna do if
there's a zombie apocalypse and that's
no worries we'll you know we'll get a
battle sort out and and just like if
you're in America it would be a piece of
Peace
it'll be over in 10 minutes
and it's true
I actually think genuine if you're
Americans and you go anywhere in Europe
you should just tell you to say you're
Canadian
I have friends that do that trust me
they go in they have little Canadian
pins on their lapel Canadian patches on
their jacket you know and literally they
per except just to get through customs
they they wave their American passport
but after that it's Canadian all the way
yeah
particularly if Trump gets back in oh
dear God you're in a big Canadian shirt
a big Canadian hat
oh not American so getting a maple leaf
tattooed across my back if that happens
again swear to God
yes
um but we were mentioning it
yeah please don't Jesus
we have on the problems
who wouldn't want to be Canadian right
right
sorry
yeah yeah Shelley is like yeah our go-to
for you know
um questionable
Shenanigans go to Shelly's house
even though we did I put a video about I
made a bacon a sausage sandwich and it
started a huge debate about what bacon
it was I was just about to say uh
because we teach you how to actually
make bacon because you just toss some
ham on that thing and called it baby
that thick cut British bacon is very oh
it's good it's just not bacon it's ham
there's already a word for that
it's not hot it's not ham it's a
difference
your word for ham is our word for Gammon
and it's definitely not good
yeah but these are all different bits of
the pig bacon is apart from the bacon
bit
the bacon
veggies calls but it's the bacon bit oh
and then you give me one I could just
imagine a pig's in their own language
Harris is going to go get his bacon
right out of the air fryer there we go
we're having a bacon why is ham
she didn't eat [__] on a pig
brown sauce is like God's tear on a
bacon and sausage sandwich
the ham comes from the back
the whole book oh my God he's got a book
well oh look yo you want me to prove I'm
a Texas boy real quick this show tells
you everything
the rest of the show we're talking about
Porky oh Jesus go go Harris
it's the best brand Source Canadians if
you need to find
um bacon it's HB or Daddy's Daddy's
brown sauce
um right Daddy's is all right the pig's
belly so it's got to be the belly where
the bacon comes from Yes
um there's there's Ellie bacon belly
bacon which is the belly bit or side
bacon
and then depending on how you cut it so
ham is the is the pig's bottom
and then you've got the loin the butt
and the shoulder the butt is in the guy
in the pig's front shoulder they missed
an obvious
they missed that obvious look
but the ham is the pig's butt
make that every what you will make that
one so when you put in the hog book into
Amazon one of the things it pops up with
is a book titled Freddy the farting
Snowman
oh that one relates to mature and the
rest of us like you know books about the
uh the the A-10
I want
the eggs
combat Journal that does sound like
interesting right we Carrie we call
Canadian bacon back bacon and it's from
the belly of the pig
Black bacon but you can get American
Canadian style bacon which is a round
thing which isn't bacon isn't that
that's really just hands
and that's what McDonald's puts on bacon
sarnes and it's just like and they
brought that over here and we all went
no that's not bacon yeah
um and now they now they put proper
bacon on it so happy days to work
um
our McDonald hash browns still good over
there because that's the one big thing
about them
what is your opinion on smoked versus
unsmoked bacon smoke definitely garbage
I like bacon
I think God invented alcohol and then
next morning he went oh man I need a pig
[Laughter]
and we and we all thanked him
um so I I couldn't be a vegetarian in
we have all the civilization we don't
have like bacon flavored chewing gum
that I know often I think flavor chewing
gum is
one thing I see is like
I'm I'm just gonna assuming bacon
flavored and see what comes up bacon
flavor there's bacon bacon popcorn
bubbles for dogs
Chris
toothpaste and condoms
bacon flavored condoms yes
wow um did you know the worst of it is I
want it it's like no why would I that's
wrong
what would the flavored condom do for
you Jay
you know
I guess you know
uh-oh
[Music]
oh please good right
um
I love this
not the conversation I thought I'd be
listening to
you
this is what happens when there's no
plan for conversation
[Laughter]
there's a ruined jackasses just like us
they came up with the idea of bacon
flavored condoms you know that right
yeah oh God here it is
Yes actually
I love how the big ass cleave is in the
bottom corner like just to show this is
how we did it there's a mallet and a
Cleaver and then like oh and the fillet
knife right right we found the body and
the murder weapon
yeah
diagram
what is taffy
whipped
it's sugar It's gotta be like sugar
didn't you
we're learning so much it's like it's
amazing
what is taffy what's the biggest state
you two have ever had Harris you're from
Texas yes you're from Texas so you'll
probably win this but I don't know I'm
gonna ask stormy as well what is the
biggest steak you've ever had
all seen
before we answer that Taffy is boiled
sugar butter vegetable oil flavorings I
think it looks like toffee to me yeah
yeah okay but anyway yeah biggest
biggest steak you've ever had eight
ounces eight or 16 ounces what we have
isn't it there's like ridiculous
steak which is like out of 36 once
I think
16 ounces as a steak
because I want to go because I
eventually want to go to America
probably taxes because in Texas
everything is bigger apparently and they
like their food
but I want a massive steak and I want to
know
I remember in Vegas I had steak and ribs
and I had um pork ribs and when it came
the ribs was longer than my arm and I
was so pleased man I'm telling you there
it is
uh Vegas has some great eating it's
always had great eating places and it's
just you know the steak is um
Vegas is great for food drinking
and smoking now but food
no one needs a gamble just go to Vegas
and prostitutes
definitely next time you're in Vegas go
to the wind for the
um the breakfast buffet thanks
especially a breakfast spot but I do
know they're very very good I was I was
in Vegas it's a personal story for you I
was in Vegas and we were um four or five
of us there and we were having a few
beers and this very pretty lady started
chatting away to us it's like three in
the morning
and uh and my mate um and she and we're
just chatting away back she's like oh my
God you're British and and you're like
what's part of bringing you from and you
know she's talking to us lovely and
she's like this very pretty red dress on
that like sequins at the top and all the
anyway
um and honestly it's about 45 minutes we
bought her a drink just because we're
polite
um she didn't even ask for it it's only
one drink babes
um and then she just said like I know
you guys aren't really up for this but
you know I can go up to your room if
you'd like for a hundred dollars or
anything and and I was the only one out
of the four of us went you're a
prostitute
cheers what a gorgeous woman wanted to
talk to that meat pie
3 A.M in Vegas
and a chatty girl comes up to you dude
seriously oh my God oh my God obviously
[__]
said he knew us at 3am leave some cash
out of it all right
okay sorry
yes love I'm a problem
I've got a story for y'all once we're
off here oh God
no no don't tell it I can't tell this
one
so I'll tell you a story I really really
shouldn't tell you
yes
okay it's just going to get you canceled
sorry
we'll be fine there's no code involved
um
yeah I was like see you next time
no we were in Vegas and um so we we
decided to go to a a place a bar that
the alcohol was really overpriced but
weirdly a load of ladies kept taking the
clothes off it was so strange and we
didn't ask for it they just did it so um
so there's there's boobs everywhere and
there's like it was like 20 quid for a
bottle of Budweiser it was ridiculous
um so we're sat there and some but we
but being because we only want to go to
say that we've been so we went at like
five o'clock in the afternoon
nobody else there so all these very
pretty ladies just came and sat with us
and talked to us and one was sat on my
lap and it was lovely but she was doing
a um psychology degree and I just
completed mine so there's this six foot
blonde girl in just pants sat on my lap
and we were talking about child
development at length I mean she was we
were talking for like 45 minutes
they're going
what
do you know about piage and she's like
oh what is it I don't know but just come
talk
um British plants are American pants
[Laughter]
neither by the end of this story so
it's a girl and she said it's like
anyway
after all the opportunity
thank you
Harris that was [__] perfect man this
is awesome go ahead Jay you said
something nice
to climax but anyway by the end of the
evening
as we're on our way out this blonde girl
reappeared and she went oh my God you're
not taking my Jamie and put her arms
around me and it's like with these
and she kept trying to like drag me back
into the uh you know this room it's a
joking messing around sort of thing
actually my mates just leave walk down
and goes what the [__] was that how come
you're sexy in America and that was it
for the rest of the things
you're a short little fat fella here
I'm like sexual dinosaur guys
what are you gonna do
whatever but yeah it was a good evening
I got a free lap dance as well that
evening good night good night
I had talked sharp about a psychology
degree that's just like 5 PM that's such
an American story I swear
one evening we did get so drunk that um
between us we all lost either our
American pants or our British pants all
of us
um two people went home one lad had got
lucky and met this um Texan girl
actually yeah um and when he got home he
went
can't find my pants
the other two of us appeared in the
doorway of because we all rented an RV
we appeared in the door of an RV in just
our British pants with no American pants
on and the other two are going what the
[__] happened to you two and that is
honestly a story I cannot tell
oh God
in just in their pants in an RV was it
the first episode of Breaking Bad by any
chance it was yes it was that's where we
got that's what inspired that's true
life story in the desert too it's I mean
Las Vegas yeah we're in California
same difference
yeah
we have state taxes that's very Kerry's
the only one that picked up I got a free
lap dance that is the generally the
coolest thing I've ever done
um and Kerry's the only one that noted
on it I got a free lap dance I'm that
heck I'm that hot I've got a free laptop
um no coolest thing I ever did was I
once walked up I was trying to get into
a taxi and I was very drunk and I was
you know like like walking like this
sort of thing and then I don't remember
this at all but um this guy appeared and
he was trying to get the taxi off me so
he started pushing me and apparently he
was like six one so I plan on my mate
saw me just go and this guy literally
just went yeah she's gonna hit the floor
I woke up the next morning and my hand
was this big and I had a piece I had a
tough stuck in it
and I was just like I chinned out a guy
in a very manly very sexy way I can't
remember
it looks like
well shucks
I don't know I want that's the sort of
thing you want on security camera in it
you know just like
this guy from Britain did this thing
like look him spark this guy out that
was me nobody would believe me I've
never I can't spark out anyone so it was
[__] genius but
what you're gonna do
um marry a girl from Smith
I wasn't gonna watch this week
yeah what we're looking forward to start
Star Trek Picard episode two I can't
wait I'm so excited and I am getting
into
um the
um Stephen lombair is a little bit
behind 24 ounce
oh they didn't go off where'd he go
that's not bad steak I want a 24-hour
steak you know if you have a steak
sometimes so much and then you have meat
sweats
yeah with the 36 ounce but I had
probably like half of it left
kicking in
there like I made myself finish it
eat sweats
at the end as well you can't do that
so what have we learned this week
nothing uh now Quantum we've learned the
difference between pants and pants
um watch Star Trek card it's awesome
don't watch Ant-Man it's terrible
um
yes go in with Marvel expectations I
think that's what we need and that is so
sad
new episode airs tonight or tomorrow
morning for y'all
y'all oh that's right yes yes yes I
gotta catch up tonight
yesterday because it was my first day
off that I didn't sleep through in like
forever I watched all of the Lord of the
Rings extended editions back to back so
that was you know just on the couch
didn't move barely I'm amazed I had a
heartbeat but yeah I watched and then
and then the first uh Hobbit movie
extended edition and then I went to bed
singing for like three weeks no no my
God
I just think that is just crap
that's a good song about Jay's lap dance
as well great to dance Too
handy for somebody I was having a lap
dance from a very attractive American
lady and I was so British about it I was
like very lovely
um so what did you do today how are you
think you've got kids that's lovely and
I'm so
lovely
no there was this there was a I got
three lap bands because um she I paid
for a lap dance
because I thought I got you just this
once I'm never gonna do this
and but then she was just like there's
this guy that wanted a lap dance and she
was like ah just can I can we just can
we go back I don't I don't want it he
comes in every week and he's horrible
and don't like him he's all handsy and
he's ugly and I'm like and I'm just like
I can't I I really cannot explain taking
out because I was actually married at
the time I really can't explain taking
200 out and this at this idea I really
can't buy another lap dance
um I'll give you a free one so my mates
thought I'd [__] off they'd come back
to me like he's be gone like an hour and
I'll just come back sat down and I went
free lap dance and then that blonde girl
I'm so sexy
uh see now you see a little pudgy fat
fella American chicks
I don't know what they see but it's not
so
but anyway so what is what what we're
coming out Harris to get away from my
lap one story because I've gotten a
little embarrassed you might notice
um what's the next enemy win in theaters
at the moment there's really not too too
too too much knock at the cabin we were
gonna talk about just a little bit which
is also I I think worth going to check
out right now got a little M Night
shyamalama llama to go to go watch
uh but my mom is in that it's I think
it's midnight shamalama
there we go I think yeah I missed
dilemma yeah you have to pronounce it
correctly mate or it's racist it's
incredibly difficult to pronounce it
took me years to even get that close you
know
but you know what movie comes out this
week we've been talking about all the
the the safe the safe kind of substances
that we could be using and in a more fun
recreational uh way so far this episode
but
there is one substance that's not
necessarily a safe and is probably a lot
of fun
no I don't know what you're talking
about cocaine bear comes out this
Thursday and it looks fantastic
honestly right it's and and have you
seen like it's inspired by I've seen the
trailer for that are we talking about
Winnie the Pooh
no no no no no but Winnie the Pooh Blood
and Honey looks good as well now this is
this is literally cocaine basser it is
based on a true story that a um a guy
for some reason dumped out a load of
cocaine out of his plane as he was
flying over um so
um and then a bear got hold of one of
the kilo packages of cocaine and ate it
and and created a whole thing now the
truth is real life the Bear died in real
life the Bear died very quickly horribly
um but they there's somebody who's
inspired by that and has made a cocaine
bear story and it's a mix of comedy mix
horror uh mix big strong out bear
um and I like the bit with like the
ambulances trying to run away and it's
like
what the hell is this bear on is this
bear
the best part that whole trailer is that
one the the kid and the one blonde dude
in the tree and the guy on the tree just
has all the cocaine all over his jacket
and he's like I don't know what we're
gonna do I don't know what we're gonna
do and the next Scene It Cuts to in the
trailer is his leg on the ground just by
himself and the bear is doing a line off
of the leg
It's the funniest thing I think I've
ever seen like the two guys with the
fingers I was safe now bear bears can't
climb trees of course Bears can climb
trees
that's when it sniffed the guy with the
cocaine all over his jacket I'm so
excited for this movie um it looks like
a stupid film but a gloriously stupid
film yes I know and they're already
talking about a sequel and I'm like oh
God no well you know hey it was a
different animal right it's like cocaine
shark or something
shark all right it's the next episode
no there's there's another movie on at
the theaters these days it's honest to
God I I've not seen it Winnie the Pooh
Blood and Honey
it looks I almost went to see it two
days ago but my Regal thing that let's
move these cost a dollar wasn't working
they still wanted to charge 20 bucks and
I was like I'm a member I have this for
a reason so I haven't checked it out but
Winnie the Pooh Blood and Honey looks
hilarious
I don't think it's supposed to be funny
man I think it's supposed to be a like a
soul movie
I don't know how much you guys are into
animation or not but have you ever heard
of a Russian animated
um show called chibirushka
stuffy we won't go into that but there
is now a chibiroshka movie out
that looks I would like to go see with
all of his little Zoo friends
chadburoshka okay so so in the original
Soviet version there was a lot of
decadent animators back in the day
because there was always some sort of
pro-western message at the end that
somehow or another the Soviet censors
never got a hold of but if you ever get
a chance to see the animated the old
animated version of cheby rashka do
yourself a favor sit down and do watch
it it's very entertaining
a little uh alligator oh he's got a
friend yeah an alligator yeah chubby
rashka was this little unknown animal
that arrived at the Moscow Zoo from a
great great of bananas I think it was
from Cuba that's how he got to Russia
and it no one knew what kind of animal
he was so he hid at the zoo with his
alligator friend
ship
I'm looking forward to I'm just looking
at the comments I'm looking forward to
that 65. that's the six that's a sci-fi
movie this year I think we'll be again
on Surface sounds stupid
um dinosaurs and ray guns
um oh I forgot who stars in it
uh uh sorry I looked at my phone for
half a second remind me
55 65 I literally just commented on it
and was like let me look at my phone
what's coming out this week I was
reading it's Adam Driver and then I
don't know the young girl with them in
there uh but she does look like she's
good as well but they had a freaking
driver's excellent it does look like
it's gonna be a good sci-fi movie I like
this
he's a really good actor it sounds so
stupid but actually the adverts look
great I'm really looking forward to that
they'll be good for them so let's give
that a go
um I I actually did look at doing a
thing I was going to look at him
zombie sorry I just I just saw a
commented once there was a film called
Zombie
movies we are going to do a video maybe
next week maybe a week I don't know
about just like the best B movies and
we've got to like modern B movies are so
stupid
um so we'll have to do that like talking
about our favorite B movies over the
over the Cent over the decades even but
um
uh what was I talking about we have no
idea
there's a film a few years ago with um
thinking it was the zombie cheerleaders
that was good it's just pretty ladies
there's Tucker and Dale Versus Evil
which is foreign
I just love that film all that Carnage
is going on around him and they've got
no freaking clue what's happening
that that Amazon Beaver are both perfect
for a little Greenery and uh and
experiencing yeah there's no better B
movie than Bubba hotep
swear to God
yes excuse me I watched it on YouTube
after you said because I thought that's
not a thing
it's Stony
has been taking something out the desert
too long yeah
one of his last performances is awesome
it's it's a great film I really I really
really enjoyed it but it's the it's the
um
it's the characters and isn't it the
acting that's just glorious I mean you
can't beat Bruce you just can't beat
Bruce Campbell you know 100
um before we call it an evening we will
I will I will run the adverts for you
Matt because you know they're always
good and then we will close out because
we've just hit the one hour mark
gentlemen
for a while ridiculous crap but we'll be
back in one second
chevrons.com
is your dedicated source for Stargate
news
which will aim to complement this
YouTube channel with news that we have
from our contacts at MGM and Amazon
breaking news about a new potential
Stargate series as well as providing
reviews and any potential updates to
news stories that we break check out
some of the news articles that we have
already at nineshavrons.com
Sidetrack also has some amazing merch
get yours today and show your support at
side-track.com
[Music]
really expensive though so I wouldn't
don't bother
um so uh right guys so
we have talked ridiculous nonsense for
an hour I have shamed myself
yes you have
we have given Financial advice that you
should not be taken oh yeah given advice
on drugs that you definitely shouldn't
be taking
a bacon comes from
we don't know for big incomes yeah now
we're at the large large cell
I don't know if you've noticed we've
gone from small pig to medium Pig and
now we're at the large South oh okay
okay we're learning good good to learn
next you're that book
I mean
Jesus it needs me wouldn't there be a
cool show like Dexter but with a hog
Slaughter you know
in steals people's pigs naughty pigs he
has to get them crack me up back in high
school whenever you're doing all your
dissecting and stuff we had to you know
dissect rabbits and and everything and I
was the first person we had to skin them
you dissected rabbits welcome to America
I did like frogs that were already like
in
in school in the US the the two things
you're either gonna dissect or a rabbit
or a cat
[__]
catches it Beyond me West Virginia back
in the day West Virginia we learned how
to dress a deer
oh yeah yeah that's the reason I was
doing so good whenever the rabbit came
everybody needed my help what you've
been dressed in like what you're looking
remove the skin off a deer typically you
call it a field dressing because you
don't want to haul the stomach and
everything else back in the bone so you
take you once you shoot the deer then
you skin it in the field you may want to
take the antlers as a trophy or whatever
then you take off the meat and then you
put the meat in a bag in your bag and
you bring the meat back not necessarily
the rest of the whole carcass so you
field dress the deer and it's called
dressing at least it's called dressing
in West Virginia and no they do not
field dressing
facts
what's
well I mean West Virginia's the only
place I know of that you can actually
take off from school to go hunting
because it's suspense hunting at least
in West Virginia because of the poverty
American pants or British pants this is
the question dear
um
I I used to skin rabbit my mom I
remember my mom picking up from my
grandad's once and she's like what have
you been doing and I was just capped in
blood
oh my skin a rabbit and I'd like to skin
like 20 rabbits
and take out the guts and everything and
um and I was so pleased but I was
literally again I looked like something
from Dexter it just looked like Saw
movie I'm just like covered in blood and
guts and like a bit of like a kidney
from a rabbit I mean [__] shoulder it
was it was like a proper horror movie
it's like a necklace you know yeah
push and twist push and twist and then
let the chicken go anywhere and then
it'll die today I learned that you're
all murderers
[Music]
we're making great progress for the
vegetarian groups right for the for that
as a cultural yeah and the vegan
poison them so we murdered the rabbits
with a brick
yeah we didn't and my dad my granddad
shocked him and we stripped and we made
rabbit stew it was lovely cabbage juice
and then occasionally he would
um with a cat and pulse go get a load of
pigeons so are you saying that you had
that you ate a brace of coneys
with potatoes lovely potatoes mashed
potatoes and roast because that's what
we do in the middle of the country
in the middle of the country we don't
you don't though you're a foreigner only
acceptable time to have roast roast and
mashes if you're at Toby carvery
[Music]
automatically think that's David blue
that is yeah yeah no it's not but I
think that's you're David blue now David
yeah a little bit of Stargate news for
you you know I heard
um
this is I know we're going to talk with
sci-fi and this is for all of the Live
members nobody else I'm not gonna tell
anybody else this
um I have heard that the agent of David
blue has been approached about return
its Target
um
that's now Robert Carlisle and David
blue potentially have been approach okay
so they're doing Stargate Universe
something
I hope so that was one of my first
agent gets approached
the the comic book ending was not very
satisfying I mean it was good it was
okay but it was not satisfying
poor [__] Eli Jesus yeah oh I've lost
one love from Kerry is that because the
rabbits my granddad made me do it it's
the sparkle alive
you know I once shot a squirrel
um and I couldn't figure out where I'd
killed it and then after a few minutes
I'd realized I've shot it with the
backside
you know
that's a pain in the ass it happens
but I used to get paid because again it
was a farm I used to get paid to kill
the Vermin on the thing anyway
moving on people love squirrels they're
just furry rats that's all yeah but they
they expect disease and things on farms
so Farms have to keep their names down
they're really destructive rabbits and
squirrels and yeah things like that
you're not allowed to kill badges
anymore but they used to kill badges as
well
like crazy
and
abandonedly killed me once I came up
over a hill and I just did his badge it
I'm going and it and I I swear to God
the badger went knock off and so I did
it's probably exactly big nails and
they're like okay now they're mean
everybody as an American not a honey
badger yeah
they're just muscle just like [__] off
if any of you guys ever read Dean
koontz's intensity yep
Badgers in the dean coops a few years
ago
Roger
um a lot of this digital stuff I did as
well but anyway I feel like our
conversations fizzling out slightly so
oh now it's fizzling out oh sure right
okay should we have um should we have a
topic next week
we should please God give us a topic
next week
um I think guys let's let's do our
favorite B movies
we're gonna have to decide what a b
movie is be movies or B sci-fi
well be Sci-Fi movies well we'll we'll
give you a little bit of leeway when it
comes to the Sci-Fi there never really
is a b movie drama
not really they're normally
apparently Harris has a suggestion for a
drama one of the most famous B movies
ever is a b is a B-movie drama it was
not meant to be a b movie though it just
happened to be Tommy wiseau's the room
I don't even know if that counts as a b
movie that might be a series
of movie that I don't even know how you
would mix why is it with like anything
cinematic oh my God it's a project
the what did you sit through that whole
thing I I have before uh but did you see
the Disaster Artist The Disaster Artist
is actually good that's great about the
making of everything but the room itself
is is funky I I watched it because I've
seen Tommy wise oh at like four
different places he's at every Comic-Con
just trying to get cash from people for
signing the autographs it's uh yeah
Shelley's misunderstood what a b movie
is so let's explain it right but we have
to set up some rules for this so
um it's a b movie it does not have to
have any bees in it even though there is
a Michael Kane movie there's a b movie
that's freaking amazing that does have
bees in it killer bees so you could have
that so
um a b movie no cinematic release
we agreed on that cannot have a
cinematic release
it can have a cinematic room yeah unless
it's a 50s and 60s movie I think well
it's okay so when I was making movies I
mean we'd have like a weak cinematic
release just for awards craft and
Festival [__] and then it's direct to
DVD we'd have like the premiere yeah
Netflix does that with some films
doesn't it now it'll do a minimal
release so that it can actually get
Awards and okay so no General cinematic
release right it's not a cinematic
release does that make the previous two
Stargate films B movies
well those are B movies just because of
because the original Stargate could
technically even be a b movie if you
want to
categorize it because it's not highbrow
sci-fi per se it's not it has a great
cast and it is cool Concepts but it's
not like it's not your high brow sci-fi
it's a fun
B-movie okay and it's great it's gonna
be my next Point does it have to be
ridiculous to be a proper B movie
no not necessarily huh so we're not just
like in Sharknado scary scary movie Epic
movie you know all those like piss tape
films they bet B movies no they're
parodies
yes yes
so
can't be a parody shouldn't be a comedy
out and out comedy
yeah I'm spitting out here I'm trying to
figure out the rules for what this is so
disagree with me
but no parodies no out and out comedies
but a lot of B movies are funny but
generally not intentionally yeah
um
I would argue it should be ridiculous
but I get I do I do get your point about
that I think like a B movies like in
cars a Lamborghini a Lamborghini is a b
movie it's ridiculous it's overpowered
it looks stupid and it barely works
a Lamborghini until
um Audi bought them and made them work
which just ruined them but um that took
me a second I thought you were talking
about the movie Cars I was like is there
a Lamborghini in there but
um but okay we're gonna do that's what
we're going to do next week then we're
going to do
um Chinese wandering Earth that was
stupid yeah I think that's a B movie
it wasn't meant to be because they meant
it they made it very seriously but God
it was stupid
um I have some breaking news here from
variety if you guys want to hear it
all right
Avatar the way of water overtakes
Titanic as third highest grossing movie
of all time from this weekend
Blockbuster epic Titanic has
relinquished its spot as the third
highest grossing movie in history to
another James Cameron Blockbuster epic
Avatar the way of water the Sci-Fi
sequel has generated
2.2433 billion dollars globally enough
to overtake Titanic with
2.2428 billion so still lost 600 million
dollars then not 3 billion though
based on what he said that it had to
make
huge failure right okay no no I just
wanted to be clear
lost 600 million dollars oh my God even
John Carter didn't lose 600 million
dollars
um but no if you
man we all know
all right
I am gonna go have my tea go have your
tea and who needs a week everybody
I was about to say which tea are you
talking about I don't need a Wii I'm
good I've stopped drinking Coke I think
Coke goes through me so just on a squash
and I don't need to win now he's on hard
mode what kind of clothes are you
talking about
that sort of coke ah
but guys it has been absolutely amazing
thank you so so much for joining stormy
bear it has been a genuine privilege to
have you back oh thank you so much I
miss you guys really have
um and so it's been absolutely amazing
thank you uh Matt um You didn't say much
which is good thank you I appreciate it
before it did the show forward
your Now TV subscriptions during the
video I did and I'm gonna whack it on my
TV when I go downstairs in a minute
oh now TV you're gonna whack Now TV on
the door okay sorry yeah
that's weird
what you got Harris well you know I have
to dress up for cocaine there so I have
to wear my
Mr yag no it says it says Mr Yayo but
the the O is going off oh no it fell off
no no it's Mr fudge to me it says Mr
Yang now not Mr Yayo it was it was a
funny cocaine preference it has
Coca-Cola along the side though but
another fail from Harris and he wonders
why he's not in the big movies
yeah yeah Mr badge yes well done sir
guys thank you so so much and thank you
Harris once again and for sporting this
sleeping giant of sci-fi t-shirt which
you can get on a mug and all sorts at
SCI dashstrack.com so you know there's a
link in the description people go and
spend money because I need some I have
actually actually do have a genuine
announcement to make actually oh my God
it's a genuine announcement personally
very exciting for me anyway I am going
down to four days a week at work so that
I can do one day a week especially just
to do YouTube videos so if the quality
doesn't go up in the next couple of
months you can generally tell it's just
me being lazy
actually this is the best he can do and
like I haven't got the argument if I
haven't got time anymore so that's me
four days a week thanks to you amazing
today trackers that I can actually
afford to do it so thank you so so much
it's absolutely brilliant so we will see
you next week we will be talking B
movies B movies pick our top five B
movies that's gonna be the rule so five
B movies are going to come with
good luck
thank you so so much everybody
say bye goodbye hey I got the I got you
guys talking for an extra 18 minutes
[Music]
[__]